less than 10 warzone rated cube fanatics
one minute 92 player's 1791 average
rating time handicapped here we go let's
roll
Game one I need to get this little timer
out of my way and please do not act up
on me
don't act up avoid Fonzie oh no oh oh no
this is not a good start
or is it time to do homework let's bring
them that homework somebody already has
a win let's see who's a top game let's
check out this guy I think he might be
up there Oh mate right around the corner
nothing happening in my game Oh a tricky
trick trick trick clean s to block
that's it just keep playing on a black
fight
keep fighting come on black you could do
it I'm gonna get a single point I'm
gonna get a single point okay I gotta
cut away from this my game is starting
in five three two one I skipped the
floor here we go back to tournament
leaders leaders leaders where are you it
wasn't shifting the leaders Oh No
is there an issue there might be an
issue another non mover Oh Oh what's
going on here I'm getting nervous this
is the second non mover let's just be
some glitch in whoever's paired up with
me doesn't get to move and I just get a
point every time I win
I'd get winds in about a minute 10 a
minute 10 I get a win somebody run the
calculations what is what is um much
right a minute 10 a minute 10 seconds
into 30 minutes how many games would
that be what's going on
- 4 - nobody's moving are these really
non movers or is there something wrong
I'm still getting the W's all right all
right back to tournament +2 wanna start
folks wanna start Oh nap 3 this guy's
gonna move yes okay we're back to live
we're back to live
Oh gonna take that night watch out this
guy already knows what I have up my
sleeve he's defended against this over
and over and over again I wonder if he's
sick of it I wonder if he's sick of
seeing it watch out for the tricky
nights I'm still gonna go now I'm gonna
go here get rid of that night Knight
takes Knight and they could grab out g7
I'm gonna Castle queenside or am i it's
a little scary over here whoa I got to
do this d6 was really sensitive right
there really sensitive
and you're crazy to give up the
LightSquared bishop aren't they get out
of there get out of there Knight pawn
push Oh trickiness everywhere
where are the tricks yeah okay let's do
this let's not be too crazy here pod
push I should have done a pawn push h3
would have been wonderful I did this to
protect my light square bishop by the
way let's push here and then push there
everybody's happy okay let's do this
right now push here next watch out for
mates tricky mates everywhere around
every corner let's take this light
square bishop give a check no let's do
here first a check here next let's
Castle Knight here check they don't have
any time no time do anything they're
down on time back to chairman I got nine
only won one game though i only won one
game on my own okay let's go here let's
roll here 25 minutes the French the
center's coming under fire I'm gonna
give that pot up the gambit land hang on
I want to preserve my light square
bishop it's Castle I was still gonna
fish for a fishing hole let's get him
out of there I want to get that deep on
one day one day not too long from now I
want to get that deep on let's come here
and I could take it next move if they
Castle but they're not castling not here
just trying to get that part could have
also taken the night oh let's watch over
this I got to watch over f2 as well
maybe I should have done this with my
queen let's do this and then this I'm on
the Queen sneaky stuff sneaky stuff
sneaky stuff
what's that even mean what does that
even mean
sneaky stuff everywhere get out of there
Bishop and let's just chill upon up here
I mean this is probably just wild and
way out of control I'm going to do this
and run over here I think no not there
no way we capture with my knight follow
up with f4 rook to f1 secure this
Knights position no just take my bishop
target g7 I'm gonna back up Queen c5 I
back up let's come over here Queens
gonna land right here it's a little
scary let's back up g7 Nate's right take
my bishop I could have taken the pod as
well didn't have any time just take
stuff take stuff take stuff take stuff
there's Knight takes pawn maybe or
something now that's not really working
is it I could defend I could defend
Queen here my Queens around to defend
Jack I could play here
I got a mate threat go he takes g7 back
to term at the dawn of time 19 19 18 17
Jonathan double those points e5 e6 chop
push another push I'm on that pod what's
wrong retaking the pond
nothing I could break the pin get the
Queen's off it's a little scary
I think Knight here would have been good
I'm in check house ready to take the
Queens that's illegal more pieces out
let's be castled I want to get this
pusher and they get my Bishop here out
of harm's way light square bishop where
do you want to be pawns get my pawns
pushing a little bit pawn push again my
knight is dead no it's not get that
bishop open up the e-file the bishop is
in trouble as soon as I do that hang on
let's watch over upon let's go
open up the a file I'm on the bishop
tricky tricky I want to get at that pawn
a7 is made they resigned back to
tournament I was going to kick the night
away with g5 and then played Bishop e6
to a2 or try to get that in at least
would have been easy okay can can of
nineteen gonna start this up or what are
they gonna fire this up oh there was an
error give me the points give me the
points if there's an error yes I got
four points pretty quick thirty-eight
I'm in second 38:33 Jackson Jackson 88
Jackson 88 okay let's roll
Bishop here's not good I kick it away
and then maybe trap it okay for cover
skis for cover skis there's a fork
Knight trade Oh kitchen sink am I
getting kitchen sinked let's do this
pawn push I take the bishop first on the
Queen my Brooke is defended if my knight
gets kicked away I'm gonna go here let's
just trade Queens could we trade Queens
please okay we got the Queen's off
let's make gonna grab this pawn get
developed King right here my rook is in
a good spot I could take here and then
defend with my knight right here there's
also for cover our pin right here and
then right here and then grab the pot
next no no jumping no jumping grab pawns
don't you dare fall for mates
okay
ooh that might be close to still me oh I
think that might have been stalemate if
I did that
oh no I would have said no don't you
dare try and steal me all right I'm
gonna keep it squeaky-clean right here
just push this pun to Victory Lane watch
out for steel manses Benko here ha ha
like you fear whenever I go for the
stalemate or the stepladder I'm fearing
the stalemate 4545 neck and neck let's
go here 19 minutes and change 45 45 41
if we get paired up that could be a big
big game a very very big game to get in
f4 Knight f3 the [ __ ] for target have
seven target f7 really quick okay I have
a little trouble castling but not really
not really cuz of that move with tempo
development push the night away okay
queenside castle and just launched my
jeep on or my epon okay here we go
incoming Knight d5 with tempo uh-oh
peace has given up more pieces and I'm
just gonna do this I want this position
to stay open it up check and target f7
next and up hitting the Queen pawn push
as well the Queen is kind of stuck clean
check Bishop check bishop mate clean
check the King goes here I give check
and then made really really soon
actually right here's me okay back to
tournament that was kind of quick 61 59
61 5941 minty
minty oh man minty minty I I wasn't
expecting the early defy rd4 tempo on
the night tempo tempo tempo tempo I'm
still looking at I'm looking I'm still
looking at I'm still looking for it
matin no it's not a main threat but
they're defending okay let's weasel
around create weaknesses or might beep
okay move my light square bishop oh I
don't even have to move that now I want
to get on the light squares let's come
over here Y square weaknesses I'm gonna
grab this pawn and then open up the H
file if not what do I do
Bishop e7 let's do this first let's do
that second its third my bishop wants to
be my no Mike smooth just move what are
you doing
rook up and over what's this rip doing
you stupid over here whoa that's a good
move that's a good move that's a good
move it's very scary over here I think
it's okay though come over here my king
is prepared to run really fast really
fast he's prepared to run oh this is
deadly this is very very deadly tricky
stuff around every corner
they resigned back to turnin 7970 553
and third can neve again was this a guy
played in the second round and the game
didn't start up or okay all right
actually I had to non-starters in one
game that was just an error all right
okay let's go with this so main line
Carroll Khan I really don't want to
enter the solid line let's try this I
think it could end very violent Lee very
violently
okay let's see this they can take my
bishop might have g5 and night here okay
what's the scoop here queen bee three
hits two things b7 and f7 I have it meet
threat and b7 gonna defend here I get me
easy to miss are they gonna miss it no
I'm on the night
hang on I'm on the night and still on
this pond it's take no no no no let's do
this first structural damage
meat no once right they're not careful
okay I'm gonna take this pawn tonight
here I have a check have to be a little
bit concerned about this square Queens
he come off queen c8 I guess and then I
want to oh okay let's take here Bishop
to c4 Queen takes pawn with check I need
to get castled okay let's just get the
cleans off and then here that can't
castle my bishops in a good spot more
development move move move move my
knight out right here just Castle
anything anything I don't want my time
to tick don't let my time tick to take
here I could have taken the rook whoa
they should check their down on time
back to tournament 1 1993 11 games in
whoa 14 minutes remaining 14 minutes
remaining bit bit alright I need to get
a really quick win why don't I go for
that Queen b6 move I think I could catch
somebody in a mate in 100 oh I almost
dropped my bishop Queen d6 I get the
Queen out of there
all right no get off of that same file
look here clean recapture it's back up
on push in the center okay let's go with
it a little scary over here let's come
up it's cozy over here
I'm gonna take my night I want to throw
a rock right here and then get my clean
on c6 right here
coming up rook on rook on stroke on d3
leading to mate or I have the Queen take
the rook I'm on the Queen and mate
threat that's me back to tournament 110
119 113 I mean I've won 13 but they're
probably just ready to win let's go
less than 13 you could do it you could
do it you could do it okay oh oh oh oh I
should just grab the pond I'll take it
now back up let's go here Castle you
know you want a castle really soon don't
you let's get more development in the
knights ready to I the e3 square all
right let's throw this in here I have
five no b4 b5 take that pun I go like
this
no let's lock it up over here I want c4
I have material I'm on the Queen they
might resign are they gonna resign okay
get that night out of there
and Knight f4 get this night the one
that's the most annoying is that night
right there an f4 and he's back I need
to get rid of them again
Bishop c4 get rid of that night and
things are a lot cleaner get rid of that
night the number one guy and I'm not
gonna take and I want to run into
discoveries check push your pond look
for me open the a file
let's take here its Castle rook a one
Queen eighty-three there might be a rook
check there is a rook check King up I
still have this now let's come over here
let's come here up we're dancing we're
dancing a little bit okay let's go over
here sneaky stuff sneaky stuff I'm on
the bishop checks over here have a
bishop get that rook out of here check I
have the rook and then mate next check
and then me just move move move move
back to tournament 130 300 159 133 ten
minutes remaining
somebody has to knock that guy off is it
gonna be me I couldn't repair it up
against him that's gonna be for all the
marbles all the marbles that's the move
I was talking about I should have been
doing earlier but I think I could go for
this still Castle you know you want to
I'm on em too
you got to do something I'm on em you
have to castle you know you do or
there's serious problems Oh serious
problems serious problems I want to take
like this Forks everywhere checks right
here hit the Queen my mouse is sticking
I don't have to move that night I have a
covered pond push I have to move it but
then I get the e5 pawn because it's
overextended what do I want to do next
let's try that let's try this Bishop b7
I still have a comfort pawn push I come
back
what about Queen here I might have been
a little nerve-racking that would have
been a little nervous okay let's let's
calm here
let's trade a little bit I have a time
edge not winning quick but I'm gonna
have to run with it just protect a
knight no matter what just go here no
matter what go here no matter what to
pre-move no time no time no time no no
no no no okay double up it's over here
okay they're down on time there's a down
time 1:19
oh man $1.99 Kappa rot oh I got to put a
dent in the lead and I can't even move
no no no no no no okay
this guy flies he flies oh you ran away
scared can I open this up oh why did I
do that why did I do that I'm gonna be
wrecked a bit reckless here ah take them
you know you want to take them I get
this in there's gonna be a queen check
oh we're gonna have a bunch of exchanges
and have a bunch of exchanges can I take
this okay scariness scaring this
scariness scariness oh there's a bishop
check no there isn't
there's a knight check coming up oh this
is really bad
oh please say it's not it's gonna be
okay is it gonna be okay
why'd I do that move I don't have any
time can I get that pine with check
right here they're gonna get that back
oh what's the time situation I don't
have a lot of time you're gonna take
that oh I should just push the pond then
push the pond next turn they can't do it
wait wait wait wait
better go quick they resign didn't I was
holding my breath right there I thought
they're gonna test my mouse everybody
should test my mouse it's a bad Mouse
test that Mouse he's he's really slow
he's really slow okay a little bit of
speed bumpy he has the lead still though
he has a lead my king was so nervous oh
it was so nervous that king of mine Oh
sneakiness sneakiness pin a knight no
don't drop the bishop build a Center
stop tricks over here on each seven
gather yourself here
okay the Queen's are coming off and
there's just no quick wins in sight
absolutely no quick wins I wanted to do
a pawn push but that's not happening
maybe I could still try for it can I get
a pound pushing the bishop right here is
good okay let's get this in Bishop right
here is probably still good at some
point
let's guard this pawn I can't rely upon
my night right here at any second what
about this I don't know stupid Mouse
stupid Mouse I get that bishop I would
just drop upon okay take that and then
let's go over here push this night away
night on b3 b6 g 3 and g 6 are often
kicked away with that rook puns okay
let's just do anything anything at all
anything at all anything at all just
move just move again back determine 193
217 he's still up there five minutes and
change he's got 17 games in even if I
get paired up with him again and somehow
managed to win I don't think that's that
that's enough I'm two games out I'm 40
points away more yeah more than two
games I got to do a pen
where are the quick wins where are the
quick wins oh not here brutal okay okay
let's do what take that night away
castle okay maybe they could grab that
pond but then I get over here with Jack
I grab that rook maybe and then hit the
night okay I want to hit that night and
then grab the e pond or come all the way
back here to hit the night let's do that
then there's a queen check grab the pond
and then grab the other pond with a
check and then grab another pond with my
knight maybe or give a rook check if the
Queen blocks check here and I really
want to keep the Queen's on the board
let's try this Oh
bishop check bishop check would have
been beautiful right let's try it now
Bishop check and where's the main this
has to be made really really soon okay
they have to give up the Queen can
resign can resign
come on oh he's just extending his lead
there's no time left okay anything no
time no time no time no time anything at
all ah
anything that's not check its anything
anything no time back determine - 13 -
37 three minutes and change uh bit bit
again again can I get a quick win right
here now just trying to be sneaky with
those moves there's only three minutes
left
ah night check doesn't work the night
has to go back pollen push in the center
ah man so tough get that Bishop out of
there and man I have to win he has to
like lose he definitely has to lose I
have to win two games that's nothing
happening oh man oh man
2:27 let's come back over here I have
that night no they have to block Bishop
here it's not working out okay I got
this night - ten - ten - ten - ten could
I just get two more wins in somehow get
my King castled over here double up
rooks watch for me they might throw mate
in on me on h7 okay watch out for sneaky
mates let's do this to defend my queen
needs to get active let's go to c7 just
in case I need more help give a check
let's come here with check at that pawn
no time back determine 233 - 57 he has
to lose uh and I have to win for sure
the assassin 123 yes he resigned back to
tournament - 52 to 57 - 243 one minute
16
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go yeah 113 I need to win this in like
10 seconds or 11 seconds to be a sure to
win and he has to lose I'm on the night
I'm gonna take fishing poles okay come
on just Castle it's my only hope
come on come on come on come on come on
come on come on let's go
just move the night are they gonna move
there's 49 seconds left in the game
their time is tickin no don't drop
you're clean
I got a primo of stuff 37 seconds
remaining
five seconds come on anything anything
anything you're gonna take my pond take
care oh oh oh just go just take my night
that's check just want a clean side
castle is anything just right here
there's gonna be a bishop check right
here throw in a check I want that I want
why don't you go to win it st. is
completed oh oh I made it I made it I
made it I made it ha ha ha oh no where
ah I had an opportunity to Oh baby
weasel have made on me if I would have
won that too I would have got it I think
he lost his last game oh man
so close ah man was he ready to go down
on time too he had point three seconds
oh man oh wait a second I would have got
that wouldn't I have because they only
call the tournament when you the game's
over
ah man uh you didn't see that let me
close out of this I got made and right
at the end Queen to be seven ah I would
have had it I would have had it I'd
smelled it oh oh that would have been
perfect
hmm how did I fall for that me let me
bring that back up hang on
good games off oh I was right there I
was trying to burn the time bearing the
time bearing the time
oh man I lost two points and I would
have been up to 20 it would have instead
of going down to it would have been a
plus 20 ah man that wasn't so bad oh you
guys have it easy whoever's watching you
have it easy man you don't feel the
sharp pain going through your heart you
don't feel any of that
no you have your little laughs you go
hehe but your heart isn't hurting oh man
let me close out of that no no no no no
um yeah actually I'm not gonna look at
that game again ever again be seven oh
man Queen check and I had to go there
was a mate until that was a sneaky move
ah man I would have been right up there
at 265 I should have just threw in a
check why am i throwing a check oh man
did that sting oh okay there's another
tournament stay focused stay focused oh
wait a second
did that one even register after all
that I'm talking did I even go backwards
two points did that game even count oh
you guys were saying that all along
oh wait a second oh wait a second the
game didn't count yes okay okay I don't
feel so bad oh so it really was they
just they blew the whistle on the
tournament ah okay well I actually feel
so much better right now I feel so much
better
so wouldn't have mattered okay I feel
realized now after that okay